it's been another painful weekend in the
corona virus pandemic the death toll is
now more than 22,000 nationwide that's
more than 4,000 have died since just
Friday President Trump has issued
federal disaster declarations for all 50
states and that's a first in US history
but seven states still do not have
stay-at-home orders in the meantime dr.
Anthony Fauci a reassuring voice for
many Americans during this crisis may
now be in trouble with a president for
apparently disagreeing with him in
public
David Beck know is near the naval ship
comfort in New York still the hardest
hit city in America David what is
happening there before we talk about dr.
Fauci you know if the trend continues
the death toll here in New York State
could surpass 10,000 today 10,000 people
killed in just the last month due to the
corona virus but there are some good
news the stay at home order appears to
be working and I'm talking dramatically
there's a downward trend with the data
from hospitalizations ICU admissions and
people needing to be placed on a
ventilator but there are still 18,000
people across the state of New York in
the hospital this morning
battling coronavirus there are now more
than 100,000 reported Kovach cases in
New York City there's also a serious
shortage of swabs used to test for the
corona virus that's according to the
city's Health Department which is now
telling medical providers only tests
hospitalized patients in order to
preserve resources
ever since Brenda fires broke out four
to six weeks ago it's been it's been a
struggle in terms of supply chain
christopher's of all is with northwell
health they are the largest healthcare
provider in New York State this week we
have enough supplies to get us through
at least at least a week the rate of
hospitalizations in New York seems to
have stabilized when you look at the
last five days with roughly 18,000 kovat
patients statewide Saturday only 53 new
kovat patients were admitted to New York
hospitals we haven't seen a decrease in
the patients just yet we've had a pretty
good uptick in the patients that we
received over the past couple of
for the past two days about 80 85
patients per day Lieutenant General
Laura Richardson is talking about the
Javits Center in Manhattan which has
been converted into a field hospital and
is far busier now than it was even last
week meanwhile the increase in reported
cases and deaths in the state of
Michigan was lower Sunday after six
straight days of more than 100 deaths
per day Cyndi Englehart just returned to
work as a nurse in Detroit after she
recovered from the coronavirus Flint
resident sandy brown who lost her
husband to coronavirus and her son three
days later buried them in a service
where the mourners had to stay in their
cars as she stood alone at the grave in
New Jersey
Jarrod Lobos died last Friday his
girlfriend Jocelyn Humana's says he had
no underlying conditions and fought
kovat for 16 days 10 of those on a
ventilator he was 27 years old they kept
saying he's strong he's young this virus
is very deceiving someone's so healthy
someone's so full of life
[Music]
Jocelin says before they intubated
Jerrod she was able to FaceTime him and
they said I love you to each other
before Jared was placed on a ventilator
joseline says Jared was treated with the
anti-malarial drug hydroxychloroquine
his mother stepfather and brother all
tested positive for the virus but Tony
all three of them are okay this morning
[Music]
there is no wonder drug yet David beg no
Forrest David thank you very much